[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy that's
here to fill you in on agents of shield
now that was a button the third episode
of the final season has just dropped and
throughout this video we're going to be
going over what happens in it and what
our theories are for the future or
rather past there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the show yet then I highly
recommend that you turn off now please
drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the video
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns on the season week by week
without the way thank you for clicking
this let's get into our recap of episode
3
okay so episode 3 takes place in 1955
the agents are journeying to area 51
aka a shield base in order to stop the
chronic comms from destroying the group
and it leads to one of the funniest
episodes ever we open with a couple star
gazing near groom Lake and it turns out
they're on a lookout for a UFO but get
something much better
the Zephyr coming out the timestream
groom lake is actually a real world salt
flat in Nevada that's used as a runway
even today it stands as part of the area
51 installation and is approximately 11
miles wide don't worry guys we got you
when it comes to Lake facts yeah now
coupled with this location is a brand
new 50s inspired logo that has a hint of
an alien TV show due to the music that
accompanies it right after this we cut
to the two surviving Khurana comps as
they meet with the villain of this
season the predictor I don't know that's
their actual name but that's what
they're called and it does sound
comic-book e-enough so yeah we're gonna
go with it lip service is given to a
machine called Helios which we learn in
the episode is an ion fusion reactor in
the marble world this may be a reference
to either the character Helios aka the
father of Circe from the Eternals or The
Olympian that was the son of the
original Titans on top of this Helios
was the god of the Sun in ancient myths
and the name hence out what the machine
is capable of back on the Zephyr Mac and
Daisy have a back-and-forth over the
latter deciding to give an assassination
order last week to deke if you watched
our recap of ever
- then you'll know that we found this
quite jarring and out of character for
Daisy so I'm glad they pulled it up it
did seem like a stupid thing to do as
Daisy could potentially even stop
herself from existing or at the very
least being part of shield she still
seems adamant that she was doing the
right thing
and it honestly seems like she's gonna
be a bit of a problem on the missions as
everyone is sort of of the same mindset
except for her it feels like we kind of
lost the Daisy we know and love but she
does get a moment to reference her old
self as when they mention area 51 being
a shield base she talks about the
conspiracies being right before joining
shield she actually used to unearth
classified information and would release
it to the public as part of a group
known as rising tide turns out she was
right about everything and yeah I
thought this line was a nice little
callback to the good old days they can't
just stand around on the Zephyr forever
though and they journey out to a diner
called the flying rocket I couldn't find
an actual location for this but it may
be a reference to the area 51 alien
center diner that currently exists out
there the group are here to get Gerald
sharp in order to use his ID and
throughout the episode they questioned
him over what's going on in the base
Coulson and Simmons journey out there
with a ladder going under the guise of
none other than agent Peggy Carter in
order to catch the chronic calm they
need to trigger an emotional response
and this leads to some of the funniest
questioning I've ever seen it is John
Wayne asked how the word moist moist
makes someone feel and go through the
scientists without finding the machine
to make things worse agent Sousa arrives
on the scene and you may remember him
from agents of Carter Sousa was a love
interest for Peggy but as we know she
just couldn't get over that star
spangled man with a plan it seems like
Sousa couldn't get over here either by
that long gaze he has at the back of her
head and I'm sure that that brings back
memories that the back of her head in
all Sousa discovers Simmons and quickly
the guise is dropped after she realizes
who he is and she gets arrested back on
board the ship Mae continues to act very
strangely adding more way to the
possibility that she's actually
possessed by isael I can't believe that
they have an isolated her yes
something is clearly going on with her
and she did die so yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see what developments
there are with the character Mackin yo
yo then start to interrogate shop and
they quickly realize he's got a
black-and-white view of the world and
decided that they're gonna have to use
deke to get the answers out of him is it
because I is white yeah probably
probably not the best time you'd be
doing them jokes anyway shop doesn't
give too much away but he does slip on
Helios and explains that it doesn't work
because it can't pick up enough velocity
however a chronic calm would be able to
provide this and it becomes clear they
want to set off Helios like a bomb in
order to destroy a vast majority of
shield Daisy also explains her thinking
behind ordering dicta kill Freddie last
week and yeah again it just feels a bit
stupid Daisy might even be a chronic
calm herself like I'm not even kidding
well I am but she just wants to help the
machines complete their goal by the
looks of it I'm still not really feeling
her character this season as it just
seems a bit jarring to me when compared
with the other entries in the series I
know from the comments last week that
people disagree with me but yeah it just
doesn't seem like she's a good person to
have on the mission if this is the way
that she's gonna operate any way she
comes across a picture of Sousa and
realizes that there's gonna be an issue
on the base at the location Sousa goes
after Colson who fanboys out a bit over
him and Daisy disguises herself as a CIA
agent I love that Sousa is already kind
of aware of Hydra infiltrating shield
and this of course has been a big pop
point in other seasons and of course the
Winter Soldier
The Chronicles enact that plan and may
in yo-yo join Daisy on the base
disguised as pilots they talk about
female pilots and I think that this may
actually be a reference to Captain
Marvel using two gas canisters they
throw them into the room to see who
doesn't react and I found this a bit
ironic as Mae has been reacting very
weirdly throughout the season
he didn't even react to seeing Coulson
back and though she does react to when
everything hits the fan something is
definitely up with her Sousa takes Daisy
to Coulson and Simmons and says that the
latter had the worst fake accent he's
ever heard
now I'm probably looking into this too
deeply but this might actually be a nod
to how Elizabeth Henstridge is from
Sheffield whereas Haley Atwell is from
London it's just subtle differences you
know one would only spy if you are from
England you'll see now the tricks souza
and lock him in their cell and may has
an adverse reaction to what's going on
yo-yo isn't much use either and Helios
activates to make things worse sharp
escapes his chair and stumbles into the
ship seeing all of the high-tech
equipment firsthand Mack knocks him out
whilst the bass goes into Red Alert and
Gemma realizes that you can use the EMP
that the scientist told her about and
the group go head-to-head with the
chronic comms at several locations on
the base it's a really good action scene
that makes the final 15 minutes of this
episode fly by and I think it's probably
been the best one this season Sousa
escapes his cell and joins them in the
fight seeing firsthand the chronic
common action simmons manages to use the
EMP which shuts down the chronic comms
but it also takes Coulson down with them
too now you may have seen the Simmons's
and lmd fan theories flowing around
online and we even talked about them
last week I did say that I didn't think
Simmons was one and here using an EMP
and and it disabling the chronic comms
to me at least does cement that she is
still indeed the real Simmons we don't
see what happens to her and she isn't
really in the preview for next week so
discuss that all below but I am leaning
more towards the conspiracy theories
being wrong
Coulson starts to reboot or he shuts
down even further but I would lean more
towards the former in the end stinger
Mack and deke convinced shop that he was
part of an alien abduction and says that
he has to keep what's gone on a secret
he doesn't but everyone thinks he's
crazy anyway so the timeline is
preserved he runs into the diner from
the beginning of the episode and starts
spouting off about alien commies from
the future and this is where the episode
title comes from that closes out this
entry and for the rest of the video I
will be discussing the trailer for next
week
so if you don't anything runed then
now's your time to turn off I had a
comment on the last video saying not to
jump right into discussing the following
episode so my bad and yet this is your
chance to check out you're still here
then it seems like Coulson ended up
going back online and we are getting a
full black and white episode Colson's I
did turn black and white just before he
rebooted so it is possible that this is
the reason why we're seeing the show
this way in it the group discussed the
day that agent Sousa was murdered and he
decided instead to save him now in order
to stop the timeline from being messed
up anymore they would instead need to
take him out of it on the day that he
was supposed to have died this may end
up involving swapping out his real body
with an LM D I'm placing this at the
crime scene Sousa could then travel
through time with the agents and we may
sort of get a reverse Captain America
motif cap of course went back in time to
live out the life he never had with
Peggy so who knows Sousa could end up
going to the future to live out the life
that he should have got with Skye I
don't know why I keep his shipping his
Daisy and Sousa but yeah let the man
have some happiness please anyway I
think that this was the strongest
episode of the season and I'm really
enjoying this final run-through time
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the 3rd episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up and if you missed our analysis
of the second episode then make sure you
check it out after this you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early
you're gonna come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
will click the discord link in the
description below every month we would
give away free movies to people are
subscribe to the channel and this Monty
can win the Marvel phase three part two
box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you have
a chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of June and the cell
be shipped out from there to ever gets
the prize so best of luck to everyone
who takes part
[Music]
you
[Music]